aufgeheizte stimmung in dresden da
hatten sich am abend gegner der korona
maßnahmen verabredet wieder auch
rechtsextreme dabei die hat mir
angekündigt dass sie vor der uniklinik
in dresden aufmarschieren wollen
spazieren gehen wie sie das nennen
deshalb ist die polizei mit einem
großaufgebot im einsatz es gab die
befürchtung dass die protestler
eindringen wollten in die uniklinik ja
und das sind die bilder von gestern
abend es kam zu einzelnen
ausschreitungen zu gewalttaten direkt
vor der klinik die polizei mit mehr als
1000 beamten dort im einsatz und zu
dieser in tellow gramm gruppen
angekündigten demonstrationen gab es
daneben auch noch gegeben
gegendemonstration von medizinstudenten
die sich da einer menschenkette
aufgestellt haben vor der uniklinik in
dresden
ja die medizinstudenten also gegen die
demonstranten mittendrin war unser bild
reporter thomas fischer thomas wie
aufgeladen war die stimmung vor ort
hattest du das kannst uns da berichten
aufgeladen die polizei war mit sehr sehr
vielen beamten vor ort gewesen es kam
immer kleine gruppen von bürgerlichen
spektrum aber auch gewalttäter die man
schon an ihrer kleidung erkennen konnte
die versuchten diesen tag zu nutzen und
versuchen womöglich in die klinik
einzudringen und die polizei ist sehr
konsequent durchgegriffen und konsequent
vorgegangen welche rolle hat die polizei
da gespielt und wir haben die beamten
diese lage der wahrgenommen ganz
schwierig tausende marschieren auf der
einen seite auf corona protestler auf
der anderen seite dann diese
menschenkette die wir gerade gesehen
haben von medizinstudenten
ja
schwierig halte auch dass die leute zu
trennen die demonstranten waren
teilweise sehr schlau gewesen in sachsen
ist es so da gilt die zehn mann regel da
dürfen nur zehn mann ups fest
demonstrieren das war gestern so gewesen
heute gilt schon die 1000 mann regel und
wie es aus polizeikreisen gehört hatte
hatte man es halt noch mal versucht
diesen tag zu nutzen diesen letzten tag
mit den schärfsten demo regeln und wird
die polizei war es wirklich sehr
schwierig das durchzusetzen weil die
demonstranten setzten die ich zum
beispiel an haltestellen und warteten
auf die straßenbahn und so wusste die
polizei nicht wann es nun demonstranten
oder waren es einfache leute die einfach
mit der straßenbahn fahren wollten es
gibt wieder heftige diskussionen über
diesen polizeieinsatz an einsatz es wird
kritisiert dass die gegendemo also auch
der protest der medizinstudenten
aufgelöst wurde was kannst du uns dazu
sagen das ist richtig die das war ein
berliner einsatzkräfte gewesen die in
diesem abschnitt eingeteilt waren und
die haben sich wirklich schwer getan
aber die regeln gelten nun mal für alle
die medizinstudenten stand mit masken da
standen mit titeln da aber das problem
ist versammlung mit mehr als zehn leuten
sind aufzulösen und die personalien
festzustellen das haben die beamten auch
gemacht es war ein ganz normales
vorgehen und wir können mal reinhören
was der polizeisprecher von dresden
gesagt hat ich glaube dieses wort katz
und maus spiel trifft es am ehesten
werden immer so ein bisschen das gefühl
wenn die spaziergänger waren mehrere
gruppen 100-150 vielleicht das bemerkt
haben sich sehr schnell ein sind und
dann gefühlte stunde später irgendwo an
einer anderen stelle wieder auf zu
kommen was wir so gesehen haben war
tatsächlich eine mischung also es waren
extremisten dabei würde ich sagen es
waren aber auch dieses typische
querdenker milieu dabei unterschiedliche
eines gruppen familien zum teil auch
ältere menschen ein bisschen p dann sind
ich war auch dabei also man kann das
glaube ich jetzt gar nicht so einfach
eine schublade stecken
ja ja das war so die einschätzung von
thomas geitner das war der
polizeisprecher gewesen die polizei war
ja sehr gut vorbereitet
wasserwerfer mehrere hundertschaften aus
verschiedenen bundesländern wenn man
sich das mal vorstellt ein krankenhaus
wurde mit 1000 einsatzkräften geschützt
das ist schon gewaltig vielen dank für
die einblicke thomas fischer